right in the last few months the eight
news now investigators have reported on
a couple of Las Vegas homeowners who've
had to fight to get their solar
installed correctly both stories concern
Titan solar and both stories resulted in
the homeowners having their issues
resolved once we got in touch with Titan
but today we learned there are more a
lot more some 20 to 30 homeowners here
in Reno Lodge complaints with the board
some were about Titan solar's
installation others about the panels not
working well or not working at all the
contractors board suspended Titan's
license but at today's administrative
hearing administrative judge put them on
probation that will give Titan a chance
to work out the homeowner's complaints
and report back in 30 days
they're under a probation from the
contractor's board at this point and I
can tell you that if you do not get it's
there if you are not responded to in a
timely and appropriate fashion between
now and and that doesn't occur as we've
been hearing I expect to see you here in
30 days and if you tell me that there's
going to be some consequences for this
contractor there the judge was talking
to a homeowner in the Reno hearing room
basically if those homeowners come back
in 30 days and Titan hasn't responded
the judge has the power to revoke or
suspend their license or impose fines he
can't make Titan do anything but if they
don't that's when the judge can penalize
them I talked with a spokesman from
Titan solar and she sent me a statement
which said in part quote Titan is
satisfied with the ncsb board ruling
today the previous suspension enforced
thousands of Titan homeowner projects
both completed and in progress to be in
limbo we are happy that the revocation
of suspension will allow us to work
swiftly on behalf of all our Nevada
customers